and they'll turn to the right-hander
carlos martinez
you're right it's a nice warm day 78
degrees a little humid yep
but uh
good news is maybe for the hitters as
the wind seems to be blowing a little
bit towards left center field
bryce harper hits it back toward the
middle off the glove of de young and
into shallow center field hoskins on his
way to third and he'll get there
harper's going to second and harper is
safe at second base
aggressive by bryce harper that puts
runners on second and third
fly ball
center field it's deep enough to score
hoskins backpedaling is carlson and he
makes the catch
hoskins coming home harper going to
third and he's there standing it's a sac
fly and the phillies take a one-nothing
lead
zach eflin
he's 1-0 e-r-a of 277
really the key for his start 26 innings
19 strikeouts only two walks
base hit to left
coronado
the 2-1 pitch
orinato rips it out to left
and it gets by brad miller
carlson will score
nolan on his way to second
and we're tied it's 1-1
mentioned earlier the 25th complete game
of adam wainwright's career and there's
a base hit
herrera over to cut it off he'll spin
and throw back in and holds williams to
a single
ramuto
motioning towards the left side hit to
the right side base head kisner
[Applause]
i don't know what he's been doing but
he's seriously been concentrating on
staying inside the
ball and it brings in tommy edmond
down the right field line into the
corner off the bat of edmond one run is
in
kisner being waved in
the throw to the plate not in time
edmond drives in tow
i'll tell you what not only did he jump
on that first pitch
i like the fact that he kept running
kept his head on a swivel and that ball
kind of came in a little loose into the
infield he just kept on going to third
base
so the cardinals are able to get the
lead runner good play by de young as
well
shift on for harper
hits a fly ball
left side arenado racing
[Applause]
long way to go
nolan being nolan
oh what a play we've got to find out how
far he ran for that ball wow
here's jt romuto he has an rbi and a sac
fly his first time
and that one's out toward right field
williams
oh he misjudged it he was looking for
the fence it's off his glove and jt will
get to second base
that's his home ballpark
and he wasn't even on the warning track
all right dede contact
need a run
three balls and two strikes
he does make contact and he'll get a run
edmond throws out gregorius and rbi as
real muto scores it's a 3-2 ball game
the 1-0 pitch hit hard diving play by
goldschmidt moving to his left he gets
up steps on first base retiring jt rio
muto taking a hit away from the phillies
catcher that was a fine defensive play
by goldie and we're going to the bottom
of the sixth inning at busch stadium the
cardinals lead the fills 3-2
and edmond with two strikes a base hit
into center
second into the 90s two for four
there he goes
three two is a base hit
badminton will stop
at third base runners at the corners
[Applause]
two outs two on first pitch to paul
goldsmith
and goldie lifts a high fly ball out to
deep right at the wall off the top of
the wall one run is in that's edmond
here comes dylan carlson safe at the
plate goldie drives in a pair
the 2-2 pitch swinging a mess he struck
him out
four tonight for carlos martinez
3-2 pitch
and he walked him
just the second walk the other was the
second batter of the game
martinez thanking his infielders as well
he should and andrew kisner
well done carlos
[Applause]
get down the right field line slicing
harper over won't get it
and first to third
[Applause]
alvarado cut that ball off before it got
to the third baseman
out to center field o'doodle's on the
run he's got plenty of room he's under
it
and he puts it away and that'll do it
for the cardinals here in the eighth
inning no runs one hit two left
will go to the ninth inning philly's
down by three
so alex reyes third pitcher used
martinez went seven and a third gallegos
three pitches in the eighth got a double
play and now it's alex reyes
the 2-2 pitch swinging a miss strike
three hoskins is up number one in the
ninth
and a line drive down out to right field
that'll drop in for a hit in front of
carlson bryce is two for four
voters in scoring position stuff is low
not taking a big hit
runner goes the pitch is low the throw
to second gets away
and harper didn't realize it
[Applause]
are they holding him on is that
i didn't see whether goldschmidt was
hurting holding him on or not
harper was one stolen base away from a
hundred they were holding him on
yeah he was holding that yes so this is
uh 100 steals for bryce harper 2-2
that time he got the swing and miss and
a strikeout for reyes
and the cardinals take game two
the final of five to two and martinez
has his first win as a starter
since july of 2018.